Fans are yelling, crying, and cheering as
the credits roll on Avengers: Endgame.
But there's another emotion viewers are experiencing:
confusion.
Major spoilers ahead, so consider yourself
warned!
The kid at Stark's funeral
At the end of Avengers: Endgame, nearly all
the MCU heroes gather to pay tribute to Tony
Stark's life and death.
During the funeral, we see a familiar-looking
boy in a suit.
It's actually a blink-and-you'll-miss-it cameo.
Played by Ty Simpkins, the character is actually
Harley Keener, the gadget-loving kid who helped
Tony out of a jam in Iron Man 3.
"Freeze!
Don't move."
"You got me."
The Russo Brothers were determined to answer
almost every lingering question in the film
franchise, and this cameo also offers a hint
about what we can expect from the MCU in the
future.
While Morgan Stark, Pepper Potts, and Rhodey
are all candidates for future Iron Man films,
Harley is one of the youngest heroes of the
Marvel universe.
Endgame is the culmination of over a decade
of storytelling and multiple actors' contracts.
Like Tom Holland's Spider-Man and Brie Larson's
Captain Marvel, the future stars of the MCU
are going to be a younger generation of performers.
Harley could quite conceivably be a future
Iron Kid.
Sam and the shield
It sounds like Chris Evans has been ready
to move on from the MCU for years, but at
least he gets to leave the franchise on his
own terms.
After going back in time to return the Infinity
Stones to their proper places and times, Captain
America decides to stick around and marry
Peggy Carter, living out his life until the
year 2023, where we see him as an old man.
But just because Chris Evans is done with
the MCU doesn't mean Captain America is.
Steve presents Sam Wilson with the iconic
shield.
Meanwhile, Bucky looks on approvingly.
Still, a big question remains: Why was Sam
given the shield and not Bucky, especially
since both of them have worn the mantle of
Captain America in the comics?
Well, there are a few reasons.
For one, Bucky really seems to like his life
in Wakanda, and he's already got his own new
superhero identity: the White Wolf.
"Good morning Sergeant Barnes."
"Bucky."
"How are you feeling?"
"Good."
Another reason: Captain America never actually
chose Bucky as his successor in the comics.
Instead, Bucky took over for Cap after Steve
Rogers died.
Cap was proud of his one-time sidekick, but
the only person he's ever actively passed
the shield onto was Sam Wilson.
Really, it's only fitting that Cap would pass
his shield along in the same fashion in Avengers:
Endgame.
Captain Thormerica
It's one of the best moments in Avengers:
Endgame: Thanos is just about to kill Thor
when he's smacked in the back of the head
by Captain America, who now wields the mighty
hammer Mjolnir.
But you might be wondering how Steve Rogers
was finally able to lift the hammer, especially
when he couldn't quite pull it off in Avengers:
Age of Ultron.
A few different theories are floating around.
Some speculate that Cap could fully lift Mjolnir
in Age of Ultron but simply chose not to.
"That's a very, very interesting theory.
I have a simpler one: You're all not worthy."
"Boo!"
"Aw, c'mon."
At the time, Cap was still struggling with
his ego and trying to find his place in the
world, but the Captain America we see in Endgame
is a changed man: He's let go of his ego and
admits Tony was right to be worried about
Thanos.
He wants to make amends with his old friend.
Just like Thor, Steve needed to get over himself
to become the hero he was always destined
to be.
Did Cap ruin the timeline?
While trying to grab a couple of Infinity
Stones, Iron Man and Ant-Man accidently let
Loki get away with the Tesseract.
This complicates things when Cap from 2012
runs into Cap from 2023, who happens to be
carrying the scepter.
Past Cap obviously thinks Present Cap is Loki
in disguise, and their ensuing battle is a
true highlight of the film.
Present Cap gets the upper hand by telling
Past Cap that Bucky is actually alive; a wrinkle
that seems to complicate the future timeline.
The fight ends when Present Cap zaps Past
Cap with the scepter, but what about the aftermath?
Fortunately, the scepter also has mind control
powers, thanks to the Mind Stone… not to
mention that Loki is on the loose.
Not only would it be easy to assume that Past
Cap's memories were messed up by the Mind
Stone, but the Avengers would probably assume
everything was Loki's work, from the fight
to the information about Bucky.
That means the timeline is still secure, so
rest easy tonight.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.